josé est ce que vous avez le temps de
voir vos enfants avec tout ça elles sont
grandes il y en a une qui a 29 ans et
l'autre 27 ans ouais donc je les ai plus
au téléphone que que devant moi oui
alors comme vous les voyez pas très
souvent elles m'ont chargé de vous poser
quelques questions interview expliqué à
ma fille
[Musique]
dit papa
paysans c'est gagner du blé
pas trop ouais pourquoi tu es toujours à
la télé jamais la ferme papa
ben comme ça au moins je peux vous voir
1 enfin c'est vous qui me voyez
thème bien faire la vedette papa
non c'est jamais été ma tasse de thé
pourquoi j'ai pas le droit d'aller au
mcdo avec mes copains parce qu'elles ont
décidé elle-même que je trouvais pas ça
bon quoi ce que papa la péter papa la
cervelle d'agneau tu crois que c'est
meilleur que le big mac
incontestablement on verra avec des
caprins tu as peur de repartir en prison
c'est quelque chose auquel je pense je
suis prêt à l'assumer mais sait jamais
avec plaisir qu'on va en prison rien et
j'essayais de teva des papas non mais
par contre comme chaque personne qui est
en prison tu fais toujours un plan sur
la comète pour t'évader c'est tout ce
que tu te dire là bas y paraît
et pourquoi moi je dois obéir peut pas
si toi tu obéis à personne ah je lui ai
jamais demandé de me vire toujours et un
mes films ont souvent résister
heureusement quand il ya des caméras
étaient encore plus courageux ou non non
ça change rien tu aimerais que shaw
paysanne mois par le scandale heures
c'est vraiment alors c'est leur choix et
elles ont le temps de choisir ils
peuvent toujours le faire dans son temps
papa tu crois qu'il aura encore des
paysans
j'espère parce que sinon ça va être
vraiment la fin de la planète pourquoi
tu voulais pas qu'ils la ferment
parce que je pense que c'était vraiment
qu'on annonce était bien mais on la
regarde et on est à fond dedans ne t'a
pas vu
l'été on est pas con non je pense que
c'était grotesque dont ça n'avait pas ça
n'avait aucun sens à les mythes que les
gens fassent un show de ce type là mais
ce qui était pas sympa pour les
téléspectateurs c'est qu'ils voyaient
pas le derrière de la ferme on n'a pas
vu la belle piscine on n'a pas vu tout
ça donc c'est vrai que c'était vraiment
du cinéma quoi s'est embêté qu'on voit
qu'on peut faire ton boulot avec des
talents au papa
c'est à dire que peut-être que pour
marcher dans le fumier c'est mieux parce
qu'au moins on s'accroche pas ouais t'as
déjà pris de la drogue papa j'ai pu mais
oui bien sûr
pourquoi tu cultiverait pas de la drogue
en disant que c'est la désobéissance
civile papa jacques août chez moi ça
pousse pas très bien et elles le savent
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'eau donc je
crois pas qu'on aurait des très beaux
pieds c'est obligé la moustache et la
peep quand on est paysan papa moi je
crois pas parce qu'on a pas mal d'un
verbe aussi un moment elle vit que tu
adores les pipes c'est vrai hein j'adore
ça oui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux